[Musique]
étranger
J'ai quelqu'un qui a un talent particulier
pour ce genre de choses, nous les appelons
l'alpha, le chien non
comme un loup
soigne tu pourrais jouer demain soir je
dois être prêt à apprendre annuler mes deux
heures et tenir le coup  mes appels
vont-ils être en réunion
ouais en quelque sorte
elle est là aussi
moi et Scott
qui
qui que ce soit ou quoi que ce soit est là-bas en ce
moment
ce n'est pas Allison
nous avons besoin de tout le monde
là-bas ne se passe pas et je pense que
tout est lié
la nicotine est venue jouer à un nouveau jeu
rappelez-vous qui elle était
Dieu
c'est comme s'il faisait tomber des pièces du
tableau alors  comment pouvons-nous te tirer dessus